[Music]
it's a waste of time what's so funny Joe
said he needed a Handler but I think
he's got one isn't that Mark's job
doesn't matter he's kind of look after
him well I am really glad you brought
that up
because good news
we've talked about it before and no look
and I will admit this especially when we
clip it and stuff on our clip Channel
the Brennan shops videos do very well
people like to make fun of him we got a
lot of compliments for the Bane
impression from the last clip that we
put up but
I've said this before and I'll say it
again even though it probably won't get
as many views this to me is more fun
the Handler
be gay lion big gay lion on his show
haters will say
and he's an idiot we know that but uh
this new well I'll just play it
I don't agree with everything he says
before anything that he said has
actually been discussed I go I don't
agree with everything he says now if you
agree with everything another person
says to me that would be the problem
right that would be that would literally
be describing Brandon Schaub and Joe
Rogan's relationship he cruises
everything romances
talking about I hope you guys don't
agree with everything that I say I don't
agree with anything you say sir your s
is upside down and I'll never unsee that
now she looks like his [ __ ] heads
upside down you know like when I say I
micro dose much funniest thing in the
world yeah I know fix your letters
prunes this morning I hope not everybody
is doing that but you know what's with
this trend now where all these podcasts
have like wall backgrounds that look
like that like you're you're in a like a
micro Brewery that has really expensive
Burgers it really does you know what it
looks like they look like they all look
like gastropubs now it's annoying you
know what Katina should be doing a food
challenge that's what that that's what
it looks like did right like all right
guys Sherry's Smokehouse and today we're
gonna yeah right we're gonna be doing
the big gay lion burger the big gay lion
challenge
where I have to eat this five pound
burger and then eat 50 of five onion
rings and then suck off ten yeah hold on
and then a handful of anabolic steroids
uh you [ __ ] suck Mark
uh I hope that you're doing it no I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up on another thing
Murray sure why is the eye so [ __ ]
wide
look at look at the eye next yeah the
eye doesn't need to be that wide dude
why why is the eye because it's bold but
why is the eye wider than the top of the
L
because it's it's a bold eye he
accidentally hit the oh okay
the Bold no I can't format for [ __ ] and
the T oh let me I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
even more and the T and the E and haters
is crooked
putting this screenshot up here all
[ __ ] up they're all wobbly it looks
like um like you were trying to make
like a a fake high school for like a
cheaply produced like pilot like pilot
for TV yeah and they're like just stick
some letters on the wall call it on a
Johnson Middle School exactly
doesn't own a goddamn level it looks
like he it looks like he filmed it in
the same place that school shooter film
that's that video that he did in the
school that same set
come on a guy named Connor
my freshman roommate at Pomona College
who's very intelligent no excuse me but
who is your roommate at the San
Francisco comedy College that's why I'm
wondering did they have dorms yeah how
did that work were you a bottom
bunk uh
a Marine Corps officer so he was a Jag
lawyer in the Marine Corps after he
he doesn't actually speak like this he
trained himself to do so
the comforters [ __ ]
because that's like you know that's less
rude somehow than actually just turning
off the person's lamp
um and then
I woke to him coming back in the room
and also like hold on I woke
you're right he he's trying to sound
smarter I not I woke up
I woke to him in the room I was awakened
by his sense
seriously to his face I was awoken by
his musk heavy but is it though because
as you can see here a 90 year old man is
lifting it with one arm and I made sure
that this was a safe setup
um I'm not asking him to like do a
kettlebell swing with it or a one-armed
snatch or something like that I'd like
to I'd like to try to say embrace
yourself against this post here
uh get enough so he's filming Brian
Callan lifting weights What's Happening
Here athletic stand so your weight's not
too much out over your knees and row it
up like that and I think he surprised
himself and that I thought was worth
sharing because I don't have a lot of
views
but he's not willing to hang out with me
in any context other than me helping him
to work out
because you'll only use me for what I'm
good for and that's me that [ __ ] and
dressing like a girl
to you mark
hey man you should you should talk on
the show more you know what else he
never says yeah bro come over
is if you're out there going um I can't
lift that now some lifts obviously don't
yell and invites big gay lion over to
his bachelor apartment
no I don't think he does race car bed
yeah he's [ __ ] his [ __ ] middle
house is dead
race car bed
push yourself [ __ ] oh can I buy a
feeling ass [ __ ]
hey somebody somebody photoshopped Brian
Callan but I'm gonna ask his dad with a
pig wait wait no not even that with the
picture of dignity
when he had to draw dignity
too hard on like you know if you can't
dead lift 500 pounds there's not a huge
benefit to doing that but something like
a kettlebell right a hundred pounds
maybe you're okay Brian's what 160 170
pounds
it this exact form of lifting uh maybe
not a one-arm row but she's so Hand in
fact your show is just going to be all
over the place then I mean look I'll
skip like halfway through he's probably
still talking about Meathead [ __ ] it's
an inherent benefit to being excellent
yeah you know and like proving this to
yourself and
um that's how I already feel about
weightlifting it's like it's not for
for anybody but me I'm not like trying
to cheat some weightlifting coach into
thinking that I'm doing better than I
did but I used to like try to find ways
to get like just survive this uh
swimming workout because
shut up
Mark you're so boring it blows you
you're so incredibly boring you you may
be the most boring person I've ever
heard you've never by the way I watch
Fitness guys yeah me too I got [ __ ] at
the gym you're just boring
because somebody and they get really
interested in it I know they're an
n-type because to an S-Type it's like
boring like who are the actual people
what is this n-type S Type Thing what
are we doing well so Royce is more of an
S-Type
he's more of a poor type yeah well
virgin kind of leans on the end type
yeah well true
any of that mean it means it means that
Fergie's n key on his keyboard is worn
out
that's the only one that doesn't have
the letter on it it's right it's worn
out completely
want to talk about the theory of 16
different personality types that's
boring until I actually meet the person
I want to go out and meet and know what
this person is and maybe catalog that in
my mind but I don't need catalog that in
my mind Mark you're not as smart as
you're pretending to be it is so
annoying I respect people more when they
act the way they are you know this this
pseudo-intellectual art is Brendan
Schaub and he might be the stupidest
person ever live
like if that's your desire to like
because I guess most guys like they're
not looking at it as a medical issue
like oh my God I'm like wondering what's
happening oh my God I have no test it's
like they're kind of like I want to get
on test therefore like how do I
manipulate my results to get that and
that's why I'm always like just figure
out the dark web and then just do it
it's going to be a lot cheaper that's
that would be my hold on hear me out
here hold on hear me out here hold on
hear me out here wait a minute wait a
minute
did he just
did he just
did he just hold on hold on hold on
Royce go back like yeah just go back
like 30 seconds yeah I'm with you
because I just advised I hold on on
YouTube let's make sure why don't we
make sure Ali can you prescribe before
testing if so what actually works like
if that's your desire to like because I
guess most guys like they're not looking
at it as a medical issue like oh my God
I'm like wondering what's happening oh
my God I have no test it's like they're
kind of like I want to get on test
therefore like how do I manipulate my
results to get that and that's why I'm
always like just figure out the dark web
and then just do it it's gonna be a lot
cheaper that's that would be my approach
to things but again I'm an n-type and
you might not be you wanna
okay maybe we are in types merch so wait
a second you just so he so he just
just encouraged
his listeners on YouTube
to illegally obtain essentially steroids
now to illegally obtain prescription
medication you know the dark web you
know how many medical you know how many
medical misinformation strikes Merchant
I have gotten for never actually giving
medical misinformation for saying things
that later on retroactively they said
were true
this is unbelievable and by the way guy
let me help you out so you don't get in
trouble every trt doctor everyone is a
scam they'll work with you I promise you
show up and go I want to take
testosterone is yours low I think so do
blood work and they give it to you
anyway that's the only the only way they
won't is if you're like let's say you're
24. they might that is correct dude if
you're over 40 36 they're gonna go I'll
say if you're 40 for sure you go in
there it's an automatic yes they'll fill
it out bro don't even make you come in
they'll go how old are you sir up 41.
yeah we're just gonna mail it to you you
could buy Viagra you're gonna you could
subscribe that Viagra mail to you now
it's not like these and those are
doctors prescribing it they're not doing
a full physical bro this whole no you
don't need to go on the dark web anymore
dude I haven't talked to my top my
doctor in months my prescription
refilled and by the way can I even can I
even leave a little further you even
have to go in the dark web there's
totally front-facing sites that you
could go right now that are legit and
buy steroids if you wanted to okay you
can Google yes and it'll work trt right
now
and you could fill out your name phone
number email address your age and say I
don't know I'm feeling kind of sluggish
in my boners ain't what they used to be
and they will [ __ ] mail it to you for
like 50 bucks a month plus the
medication it's true no I'm just telling
you like so so this whole like I'd
rather just do it the heart why would
you do it the hard way you could do it
easily right now follow the rules
um and I'm like by tomorrow not sure
don't sleep drink alcohol no those are
certificates but at the same time
those
uh might work right drinking alcohol not
getting enough sleep these are classic
things or all you got to do is get a
prescription for it once
and then you have it on you and then you
order all the stuff online from front
facing sites and if they say anything
like our prescription and that's it no
problem
it's the same way in those states where
it's medical as long as you have a
medical law on you they don't know if
the the weeds you bought was illegal
that's inside the thing you know what I
mean there's no way to know yeah maybe
don't bring up drinking and not getting
enough sleep right because now I'm
feeling personally attacked yeah no
seriously is he attacking us back I
think he is
that if you came to me and told me like
I'm not getting any gains and I'm like
well what are you doing I'm not sleeping
every night and I'm drinking alcohol
that would suppress your test right
wow that's why they call them low test
merch
what do they call them Casey do you have
any idea of how to spread your
testosterone no
you're like this gentleman doesn't have
testosterone he wouldn't know as uh
alpha male Chad who constantly has high
testosterone I just wouldn't even it's
not something that I've ever had to
concern myself with now
he's in he's trying to be funny and lean
into it is he I hate him he's failing at
it
he's failing at it
that's about as much as I could take a
big a lion for today unless you want to
do more I think we got about no big gay
lion is exhausting and he makes me
sluggish it's short it's short hits with
him you know what I mean you got to do
short hits